so are you able to disclose nothing
about my life dance around why you feel
exhausted
no i'm sure it'll make sense to people
eventually it's been a tiring few weeks
um have you been
good
uh back from australia
uh and that's uh that was a fun that was
a fun trip was able to visit i just
realized my camera is in kind of a weird
position um
was able to visit uh the summerfall
folks making this musical uh in
melbourne fantastic and also hang out
with my
friends from the band tripod in person
which i had not seen in person since i
think
2016.
so we've had like a million zoom calls
because you did the yes assassin's creed
stuff with them right they wrote some
songs for that right
yeah yeah what it's like it's like a a
fun sort of just round robin of stuff
because
they initially reached out to me
they got hired by the melbourne symphony
to do an evening length show an
orchestra cabaret show of like songs
about being gamers basically like a
comedy a comedy sort of quasi musical i
have a memory of sitting in that room
listening to some of those songs yeah
it's because it's like my favorite thing
ever um
it it's so yeah they basically started
writing these songs and then
um the guy who who had hired them on
behalf of the the melbourne symphony
said you should really have a kind of
fourth
uh leg to this operation that can handle
the orchestra side of it so initially i
was brought in just purely as an
orchestrator but they really kind of let
me into the creative process of the show
they were building and integrated me
as a conductor and as like a sort of
character in the show which was a lot of
fun
um
and um
and we kind of egged each other on to go
into crazy directions and then that
i was actively working on assassin's
creed syndicate in parallel with that
project so then they when ubisoft was
like we need to write songs
um i said you know i know these guys who
can work on the lyrics and
and or just co-write the songs
um
i think they were officially hired as
lyricists but they they
contributed huge amounts of music as
well
in that um so they were definitely
co-song writers um
amazing stuff uh that they did
and so then it was like yeah just need
every excuse possible to keep working
with these guys so we've done
some spec stuff
um over the years and a few little odds
and ends and then and then yeah uh when
this musical thing came up it was like
they've got to be because they're not
just songwriters they're also like big
nerds for musical theater so it's like
exactly
the most perfect people for the job
that can be imagined they're they're
they're incredible musicians songwriters
um theater nerds and die hard gamers
uh
and uh so yeah apparently one of the
recurring jokes
was when one of them would go play like
like pvp kind of like halo or whatever
after we'd finished the project whoever
he'd play with assumed that
hit like gatesy is the guy from tripod
he said that there would be like
essentially a curse word in their house
of someone would yell wintry whenever um
gatesy like won around in like a kind of
a pvp because the presumption was by
knowing me he has some kind of insider
like of all game of all
games the secrets of video games yeah
like by knowing the industry
that's what it is yeah exactly it was
like it's like i had cheat codes to all
games
that have ever existed and so yeah if he
won it was clearly some unfair advantage
um
that killed me i always thought that was
the funniest thing i was like god i wish
uh i had that
look it's marcus phoenix how you doing
welcome to the show
hey everybody how are you doing marcus
phoenix
it's my worst john dimaggio that was
solid
i mean you know doing a good job
dimaggio is is is not
it's not necessarily a good sign in uh
yeah animation industry is it that was
the big controversy
what was
what was the big controversy what did i
miss people people doing people being
hired to do a good job dimaggio for uh
was it futurama
oh yeah dude
but did that didn't that um immediately
yeah it died down very quickly i think
yeah like it never actually went to air
that like they never actually i think
recorded anything or finalized anything
didn't they basically resolve that
before they even really kind of started
yeah and i i i you know cue up the
people to go troy's told this story
before uh but when i pretty much first
got into a like always in that voice
full on a second pause
mike how are you
i'm i'm a bit exhausted yeah i'm a bit
tired do i look totally
the [ __ ] is going on with your lighting
bro my lighting i'm looking yeah i've
not got it set up apologies let me sorry
you've come to expect a certain standard
from me lighting-wise yes i've not i've
not lived up to what i'm meant to be
doing for you on this call troy and i'm
sorry thank you it's it's
this is coming up on your peer review
[ __ ]
yeah most people don't realize
my team that is that is a big commitment
every month it's great
and trivia about this show that we have
uh we have quarterly reviews where we
give strong evaluations
we pass we pass around the speaking
pillow
by the way backgrounds yeah debbie and
hr last time was like guys we really
need to be better about our
communication skills like i know she
handled those worksheets
and then it was we're improving though
yeah well everybody took it to heart
clark in accounting though is like still
being slow on my check and there's
absolutely no suggestion of hostile
takeover that we have no ilana this time
absolutely none she hasn't been run off
of the uh
runoff of the we fight him
we had the group yeah
we figured it out we felt that
ultimately alana had to go spend time
with her
there was a weekly new dog yeah and we
we as a team decided that our best
opportunities lie elsewhere yeah i
thought it was great
we will continue to upload to her
channel and may occasionally invite her
on
yeah that was paul that feels like the
right thing to do i think it was great
that like banjo kind of got
his
own
green card so to speak like alana was
like
now i'm officially here in this country
and banjo's like now i'm officially
yours that was kind of cool
and the priority was fighting badger
didn't want to be with some
like a person who was going to get sent
back any moment that was what it was
mike bithell hi troy baker guess what i
am like totally
timestamps totally hooked on right now
love it and you're i know you're gonna
laugh maybe even i roll
i'm ready
and now the shipping forecast brought to
you by the met and the maritime oh
really you've gone into the is it
helping you sleep he's helping him
love with it if you guys if if you're
listening or watching don't know what
this is there you go okay
[Music]
yeah i've never met someone outside of
the uk who has any idea what this is and
to be honest probably below the age of
40 i would say most brits don't know
what it is not that guy um so there's
this thing i i love this app called
we're not sponsored by it but i love
this app called calm i'm i was pretty
addicted to watching something before
to fall asleep to
um and it's just it's really really bad
for you it's just you don't get good
sleep it's absolutely like coming again
yeah yeah so i really wanted you know
i want to sleep better so i was like
okay what can i do but i still do need
something for my 80d brain to not just
go crazy with so someone suggested the
the app calm and there's a whole bunch
of different things you can do there's
like there's matthew mcconaughey who's
going to read his book tell you first
boss get away fast i get up that was you
doing that impression for me that i
would love i love
[Music]
take my shirt off right quick
so
but i love these books i really enjoyed
the green light i heard it was great
yeah i haven't read it or listened to it
for the record i'm still waiting for the
story that you've already okay okay
sorry
um so
call them app it's okay keep going the
calm app and so one of the things that i
fell in love with was
the history of the transformers as read
by peter cullen so optimus prime is is
reading to you how am i not listening to
that but how does that mean
how do you fall asleep to things where
the information is valuable
because everybody
optimus prime there you go are you gonna
how many pieces 1200 are we looking at
what we're looking at here uh
10 thousand
jesus he's quite big and he transforms
as well
does that stand like well he transforms
no way yeah he transforms
that's my i get a big lego set for every
big mile so i want to track down an
original g1 megatron just to have it oh
the gun never yeah you can't find
megatron's not a gun anymore i've got
him somewhere i've got him i've also got
megatron up on the wall behind me though
let's make sure that sounds like on
point
so wait that's the first one that
introduced me to this was was optimus
prime telling me about the transformers
it's amazing
i have no idea how it ends by the way
because i've never made it through
um but then basically that that
addresses the point though like i i
find that
falling asleep listening to something
that is even remotely interesting
backfires uh
because i either
do manage to fall asleep and then the
next morning i'm like [ __ ] what was what
was that again and you like rewind you
know and start again and then you end up
in this loop of the first chapter for
eternity um or
um
i kind of delude myself into thinking
i'm i'm hearing it and i sail through
and then i realize i didn't
actually retain or learn anything i
think that the shipping podcast or the
shipping podcast the shipping forecast
the shipping podcast is about two people
whether or not they should be in a
relationship um the shipping forecast i
think would be perfect for you well it's
also meaningless unless you know what
the terminology means absolutely and
that's the thing but they're saying so
the the history of it is it was first
published in 1861
it was then broadcast by bbc4 and has
not been off the air since 1924
except for once during the war because
they were afraid they would provide
valuable information too
the enemy so but what it is it is
literally the the information of the
waters that are surrounding
the uk to provide information to
maritime people to make sure that
they're not sailing into dangerous
waters and just here's what you can
expect going out
um and since they started producing this
it's like saved countless lives like
their their the attrition and the rate
of dropping from from uh shipwrecks like
dropped dramatically because they were
able to give information so
but everyone now in the uk it's kind of
like become a part of british culture
it's like how the flag used to wave on
tv at the end of the day in american tv
right same kind of vibe it was the sign
off for the channels like we would play
the uh the national anthem and the flag
nationalism we did valuable information
and save lives yeah it's exactly the
same thing
but the guy that just that does that's
just you trying to collectively atone
exactly
you kind of gave it to us you're our big
brother we learned it by watching you
uh let's talk about india for a second
um
that's my apologies so the guy that read
it for the bbc is the one that's putting
this out and he gives a great little
prologue it's like here's what this is
because most people outside the uk don't
know what this is
but the way that he reads it there's a
certain like rhythm to it
and it's so great it's like um
fitzroy
uh fitzroy moderate 1000 clearing by
o600 tomorrow morning and it's just
perfect it's like someone reading out
like a vector file it's just maps it's
basically expressed as a series but it's
familiar words and so you're like okay i
can get a track
my lunch is here oh fantastic thank you
um
welcome to asmr troy yeah i was gonna
say i love that word
chimichanga
um i didn't have time to grab lunch
before before the pod
so anyway i thought you would mike
appreciate that i appreciate that does
it does it just lull you to sleep 100
you should totally check it out because
it doesn't do what you're describing
austin that you can't follow it you
can't take away any information from it
it's actually useful it just sounds like
it's like laura mipson but like said out
loud oh you know laura mipsum is troy i
don't know please introduce me but i
don't know
i love it so lorem ipsum is fake latin
that's used when you're doing like type
setting or you're like doing you've seen
lorem ipsum on stuff it's basically if
you're if you're doing like you want to
do like a graphic design template or a
website or something where you just need
like a block of placeholder text it used
to be the the typesetters would you use
like stock like you just there'd just be
certain poems or paragraphs but what
happened was that the per the client
would read those paragraphs and like
give you feedback on that so what what
they eventually arrived at i think laura
memphis has been in use for at least 100
years i would need to actually look into
the history of this but basically it's a
it's it's gibberish latin i assume i
would have assumed it was far more
recent i didn't uh well the opening so
the first sentence is always um lorem
ipsum dollar mitt
something else which basically means the
most important thing is that this text
doesn't mean anything
and then i really want to get it
right
and then you just do like randomly
generated uh latin underneath that go to
laura ipsum.com austin and just they'll
have like a history section b or a lot
of please
austin fiorella but like it's it's a
really cool like it's just basically
gibberish text so so what i'm saying is
laura mipsum it looks it's deliberately
chosen because it matches the general
word length and letter
like frequency of english so if you look
at it on a page it it looks roughly
englishy but in actuality it's it's
absolutely chipperish sounds like
america so this blows my mind
this um this blows my mind apparently
like certain fragments from laura mipsum
are
are like close enough to real latin that
they're they can be like fragments can
be found as far back
oh wow as
casserole wait but it's placeholder
there's a lot of real language then no
it well it's it's it's basically like
latin it's scrambled latin but it says
um
used as placeholder text this part blows
me away earliest known record of it is
from the 1500s when a printer used it to
make a it says a specimen book which i
assume would mean like lauren if some
dollar
mitt ahmet or sit our met this has got
to be used somewhere as a spell
that's right yeah it's it's actually
like
a request or whatever i swear i swear
because the first sentence it's kind of
just a standardized thing you always use
the first
oh my god
a game that i'm in right now and someone
was like hey do you want to put any
easter eggs i have to do this
oh my god
but make sure it's like laura mibson
bethel
right wintery
pierce baker oh no i'm completely wrong
it doesn't mean this is fake text it
means nor is there anyone who loves or
pursues or desires to obtain pain of
itself because it is pain apparently is
what the the opening sentence always
means sorry i need to put my life
according to this beautiful there is no
literal translation though like the
first sky is based on an actual latin
kind of phrase but yes as you say it's
been kind of garbled over time but yeah
it's like yeah basically now troy you're
going to spot it everywhere
now we've pointed out to you you're
going to know that you're
in like whenever you see like a
placeholder whenever you see like a
graphic design portfolio i don't have
and you see a graphic design portfolio
if you see like look for it in like when
you're look when you see like a
character reading a newspaper in a movie
you'll often see they've just filled it
with lorem ipsum um there's a um there's
a you left off the second half of the
sentence the of the original source
translation nor is there anyone who
loves or pursues or desires to obtain
pain of itself because it is pain
but occasionally circumstances occur in
which toil and pain can procure him some
great pleasure
that's the uh i am pretty ironic
it's a writing design to save time and
effort because you're basically avoiding
someone giving you feedback on the text
it's also i'm pretty sure uh seen in
naruto
but
you've seen it you're not going to be
able to
you're not going to not see you're going
to see it all right yeah i always i
always know that i've found an
accidentally
abandoned or dead website that's always
the giveaway where you you go to google
something and you're way down in the
results you know like trying to find
something very specific and you come
across some like wordpress thing that
was never actually finished and all the
text on there is
laura some something or i remember when
it's like when i was first starting out
as a graphic designer i used to use i
used to use i used to have a text file
that was just lorem ipsum just it was
just a text file of like copy and paste
into things and now if you right click
in most like adobe products or whatever
on a text box it's just an option to
fill it with laura memphis and by
default like it's just it's just this is
going to be the name of my fake
assistant
lauren laura ipsum is
so here in a in a related vein something
that ah did you book that hotel guys i'm
sorry miss ipsum yes hi
miss ipsum dictated
smithy um
i got this weird um
um
like
at some point long ago
um i had set up a google alert where if
my name shows up in like an article
it'll it'll just forward it to me we've
all done it well none of us none of us
are above that let's be honest the three
of us did not get into cool positions by
being humble people we don't have to do
that
googling yourself it's the internet's
version no but this is google
auto self forwarding uh it was a good
way to find uh like in the early days it
was if a game mentions the music in the
review i didn't have to google every
review site
because that was useful clippings for
future like pitches for panels explain
your ego too
we're all very proud of you
so yeah so of course
you don't have to explain ego in me and
troy you're like that's the same i'm
just saying i'm saying
it can serve ego and have
you know five percent of that be useful
pragmatism so
i got a google alert the other day for
this is just one of those like this is
the new version of lorem ipsum i'm quite
sure because
um a website called
vietnam reflections
uh which
i don't
it looks like it's some kind of like uh
you know what's the what's the website
where you like upload a graphic design
and they'll put it on anything uh like
on a coffee mug
or um
yeah one of those kinds of so this
appears similar to that because here's a
t-shirt available that is just the
journey soundtrack cover like as a
square
on a t-shirt
and it goes here is the
here is the um
it says like related articles which i
don't even know what that means
presumably similar clothes but this
there's no way this wasn't generated by
the most batshit crazy text generator
because basically instead of nouns they
use names i was sitting here reading it
and i found myself just enthralled by
the bizarreness of this it goes
every year dantes
can be seen queuing to buy the latest
models even when they already have a
perfectly glorious phone that does not
need replacing their cuthbert was in
this moment a wonderful jocelyn when
angela is more popular it reduces the
number of brick and mortar stores which
create thousands of retail jobs also the
rise of wilfred boosts the development
of the quick-witted industry and
distribution process the frank dante
comes from an exclusive ethel bert one
cannot separate brennas from likable
ernestos having been a gymnast
individual sports also provide better
opportunities for dominic's to challenge
themselves by getting goals and
achieving political best i'm about a
third of the way that's google i'm gonna
need you to record this
and make that my newest calm go to sleep
thing
get peter cullen to read that for you
isn't it amazing it doesn't feel ai
generated where that's what it is
it's right on the edge of making sense
it's one of those that's it's just skirt
like because all those sentences
individually have a sort of grammatical
coherence but it's just sort of going
nowhere
that will be designed to fool google
into
i think so google's constantly browsing
there's no fool in google it's not
filled with google you can't it's it's
aware it's become synthetic
because he was the one i realized right
so basically instead of laura mipsum
which is clearly placeholder nonsense
this is my assistant this is nonsense
designed to trick the the the little
google bugs that go out around the
internet and find stuff so i shouldn't
have bought 20 of these t-shirts you
should buy 30 of those t-shirts because
someone went to a lot of effort to get
you to find that virus search result
yeah why are you on that page you're on
that page because they had
was it austin
my name was was was in there because
it's literally my name is on the t-shirt
because it's the album cover from
journey on this so-called
um so but clearly what you're telling me
is that this is a credit card phishing
scam no well it's definitely pushing you
towards some kind of weird kind of
probably drop ship kind of not drop [ __ ]
let's find out mike give your credit
card number yeah i'll do it now i'll
just hold it up to the screen anybody
want to volunteer let me grab that for
you
okay yeah i didn't know what it was
and
every now and again i saved things where
i'm like when we're back you know when i
on the next
play watch listen round up when i have a
moment in which i can ask a random
question and somehow your lorem ipsum
teed me up perfectly
to to so i've done my part what else you
guys got for that uh i teed that up
perfectly
yes no i'm saying i good job i've done
my contribution i did nothing i'm very
proud of you both you've done really
well
this is a great podcast you should be
very proud of what you're achieving so
we just ended here should we just send
alana like here's our episode
we nailed it half of them it's 19
minutes long yeah i i would pass along
this uh to you and we won't do it for
alana because she you know she's good um
i was in toronto
the canada one
um and i had a wonderful time
just kind of hanging out with fellow
nerds it was it was a really cool show
but there were a lot of people that came
up to me talking about how much they
loved
the podcast
and
i don't know why
um
you don't know why they love the podcast
or you know what they probably need to
tell you it was it was it was so it was
so encouraging you probably disparaged
them publicly after saying like i can't
listen to anything else you have to say
you basically did the alec guinness like
you need a life you're clearly insane
um
where is the person who looks after you
where are they exactly
it was it was so encouraging because
they're like this is
a lot of people have said you know it's
their fall asleep app it's their
shipping forecast makes no sense at all
i can just fall asleep to it
i whenever you talk troy i just
that's what makes me realize i'm on the
internet too much thanks my favorite
it's my favorite almost good fortune
cookie closing
yeah which was you remind me that there
are greater things in life
it's like oh i
almost stuck the landing on that one you
inspire me to do better to look for
better yeah
that's nice that is buggy right now is
it mine
my internet connection is unstable
yeah you seem very clear here well so
but you were saying about how brilliant
we are please please continue people
were very kind and and so many people
talked about how this was the
the podcast they found us you know in
the middle of pandemic and it was
something that um they could latch on to
in the conversations they just they love
it's it's funny because we don't think
about this conversation happening
for anybody else necessarily i think
that's why it works to be honest i think
if we were very much broadcasting i
think we'd become obnoxious i don't know
or more obnoxious maybe i think more
more we already know we're pretty
obnoxious
yeah this is just a nice excuse to hang
out with uh three people i i think are
great
what is happening this week like
i know burning man is happening this
week for anybody who cares and that's
been an interesting challenge apparently
it's quite windy
never been to burning man never have
never no desire whatsoever i think it'd
be my crowd i think i'd be the grumpy
british guy in the corner it doesn't
seem you are what i i never heard of it
before moving to california so are you
aware
of burning man at all like is it a holy
canadian or canadian california thing
i'm aware of yeah it's definitely like a
californian but i'm aware of it from
osmosis from pop culture and stuff i've
seen
tv shows where they've had an episode
about burning man or whatever yeah for
those who are not aware burning man is
an annual festival that's been going on
for like
30 years maybe 40 years something like
that
it takes place out in the middle of
death valley on the playa
and it is a
the the space is enormous it's something
like
10 miles in in diameter or something 86
i i typed when was the first burning man
in 86 28 20 22. doing a really good job
of being the uh the one on google i love
that i really appreciate it
yeah i'm doing my
best doing well
um
the
it's it's a combination of like you know
kind of bohemian culture and and and
celebration of that it's it's um there's
people that definitely
this is their time to experiment with
psychedelics or or other substances
uh both nefarious and not they're also
very exhibitionist like when you say
bohemian it's sort of the impression it
creates is in the spirit of that kind of
like mad max very sort of vibe it's uh a
kind of clothing semi-optional thing for
like ten years of thousands and by the
way i i fully reckon i am
in the extreme desert
boiling heat is probably both welcome
and also just like every year a month
after burning man is a lot of skin
doctor like i got a weird thing i got a
[ __ ]
yes yeah you 100 have cancer um the i i
am explaining this from very much of an
observational
uh outside
second you know hand i i have friends
that that that have gone or con or
continue to go
um so i i've never been so i i cannot
speak to it personally i for some reason
just have a weird thing about it and i
don't know why
um
it's weird i wanna be one of the cool
kids
i
don't i don't like some people feel like
they miss the boat on a thing so they
put up a sort of psychological defense
barrier that goes i have absolutely
in any way succe to me and part of it is
once you get there like if let's say you
roll in and you set up camp
then first of all it's like it's six
hours just to get in because it's just
one road and a [ __ ] ton of cars um but
then once you get in people can come in
and set up around you and
set up their camp attached to yours so
you can't just leave
um you're there and it's like
two weeks long i think up two was it
really two weeks i just assumed it was
like a weekend
no i think my my impression was that
it's a week but i don't think it's like
it may be it may be one week i mean
setting up some of the stuff there right
some of the stuff is massive yeah and
the installations are incredible like
like what people do there's incredible
demonstrations of art from
just sculptures to light installations
um to in like places that you can
literally just they set up temporary
structures and the the cool thing about
it is at the end of the um
the burn they burn the man which is why
it's called burning man it's a huge you
know effigy of of a person that they
burn
and there's and it's massive like it's
it's like
the size of 30 feet tall or something
yeah i mean it's just unbelievably huge
and this is very much everyone who's
gone has been like this is very much of
a spiritual journey there are people
that have like you you write something
that has been one of your great regrets
or or whatever it is and you throw it
into the burn it's it's very much of a
uh
quasi-religious spiritual experience for
everybody so is that like an
organization
is it like is it like this is like is it
like a like a
like there's a company that runs it or
is it very kind of folk kind of just it
happens like what there's there's
desperately an organization yeah like
there there is there's an infrastructure
and a lot of it is
they are really starting to crack down
there's been some people who services
have popped up saying hey do you just
want to show up we'll set up your camp
for you so that
we can have everything ready for you you
can just roll in and
the people that run burning man will
show up and go
you get your tickets they're like no
we're just here studying i was like get
your [ __ ] and get out of here and
they'll kick people out because they
want people to have the full experience
of no you need to come in
they don't want like airbnb as they want
like right and there's there's there's a
bartering system so it's like hey
whatever you have you just give and
there's no selling of anything um so
it's very much of a we're trying to have
some sort of utopian culture that's
happening and growing up in the i'm not
necessarily conflating these two or
drawing too too tight of a comparison
it's very loose but
every year we would go to summer camp
and
there's something about going to
a place where you can kind of separate
from the people that know you especially
like your parents
and i don't know if you guys have
experienced anything like this but i was
always afraid of
being my real self
when there was somebody else who knew me
from normal land
who could go [ __ ] that's not you so
it was never
i never felt uninhibited enough to just
go
i like this because i thought that
someone would always call me out on my
[ __ ] but going to summer camp
the the church services there were
always more amped it was way more of an
emotional experience and so that that
always like the music was was way more
geared towards like let's really have
this intense emotional experience it's
not a cognitive thing at all it's all
experiential
and so i understand the
the experience of that
um and then you you say i'm gonna do
this for the rest of my life and then
come mondays like
you're back to your normal [ __ ]
so i don't i know people have that
withdrawal of the of the week after from
burning man i i have friends that are in
a form of depression after it because it
was just
they lived in a perfect place where
everyone got along everyone there was a
community of support around people
um so i understand
that aspect but um there's a sound
designer named robin arnott who had an
experience like that very similarly at
burning man and was like you know sort
of
you know
sort of tripping balls out of his mind
on mushrooms
um and had this really kind of intense
personal experience so much so that he
dedicated years of his life to creating
a vr
like a psychedelic vr experience to
essentially bring this to anybody
anywhere in the world called sound self
where you it's kind of amazing actually
i i i tested it early on uh for him and
even gave him some source sounds for it
from our banner saga recording session
of all things
so this is a while back but he um he
hooked basically created an interface
where you put on a piezo mic around your
neck
um and you like hum and and it basically
is just sort of taking in the vibrations
and the frequencies in this so you can
be very quiet you know because it's a
piezo that's built around the contact
with your
almost directly vocal cord
just so people know a piezo mic is
something that they'll use like they'll
put it on a piano they'll put it on
different things to where it literally
is it's you know where i first learned
what a piezo mic is go from playing uh
the sierra very original bad fmv game
swat
uh yeah where they talk about how police
and special forces wear piezo mics
because they can whisper
really quietly and hear each other
completely clearly in their in their
their walkie-talkies i never knew what
that was until i played that game but
that was um so yeah you put on a piezo
mic and it plugs like by usb essentially
into your computer or to whatever you're
using for the vr and it and it used he
created these algorithms that take you
in this kaleidoscope of visual and sonic
craziness and it'll feed back on the
pitch in the headphones that you're
humming and create a whole kind of truth
oh it's kind of resonant
yeah exactly so you'll see people using
it just kind of going
and inside the vr is like
basically an acid trip without the acid
like it's it's pretty amazing actually
what and he did it you know hoping like
he made this game called deep sea for vr
that it actually wasn't initially vr he
made it by taking a gas mask
blacking out the the goggles and then
building a game around it so it's an
audio only game that takes place
underwater and it is
[ __ ] terrifying um and because you
have no visual reference you can have
your eyes wide open and you cannot see
[ __ ]
and it and it was so viscerally kind of
a while ago right that was like 20 10
years 10 years
yeah it was a good solid 10 years ago
because i remember him presenting it the
experimental gameplay workshop at gdc
and then that's what led him to go
pursue sound self because he thought
i need to use sort of the my powers for
good i made the most terrifying game
ever and then he went and had this
amazing burning man experience and
basically said you know now i want to
make it
is it still on some platform sounds
selfish a techno
a technodelic hmm that sounds like it
seven out of ten on steam so it's on
steam i maybe try to hook this up man
check it out or or he's a super
interesting guy and like he spent years
of his life committed to i mean he for
all i know he may still be working on
some current iteration of it i haven't
talked to him in a little while but it
begs really lovely guy it begs the
question
uh of my other two people here what is
art are games art um
oh roger ebert um
would you do psychedelics
any desire and then and this and then
the follow-up question would be would
you do it
obviously presumably you mean in a
country where it was legal troy you
you're asking that question christmas
one would never dare dream of breaking
the law anyways i don't
think is it still considered i don't i
don't honestly don't know is it is
illegal in definitely does california
have laws i feel like those are the
rules you have to live i don't believe
that mushrooms are
uh but i i don't know if they by the way
yeah absolutely we're not we're talking
in a legal
area abstract yes totally abstract like
if you're in amsterdam let's say where
it's whatever fine all
right any any uh implication of
violating uh government laws uh we three
are absolved alana may be still
considered liable alana will break any
law that any man dares place on the line
a quick pin this dates this podcast but
mikhail gorbachev just died
oh really holy [ __ ]
i didn't that feels like the end of uh
era for sure
92
damn he held in there for a long time
he's been out of the uh public eye for
so long that i actually wasn't no i
wasn't aware i didn't think he was still
alive i thought he had died years ago
anyway back to acid what would you do
we're not going to honor mikhail
gorbachev necessarily you know it's
funny
someone who um
uh
i i had a period a few years ago where i
went down a sam harris reading binge um
and he was someone who was interesting
because
he
you know obviously was this sort of
vocal
you know sort of so-called militant new
atheist along with hitchens and dennett
and dawkins um but he always stood very
apart from the rest of them because he
was very interested in
like what is the what is the scientific
and or just humanist grounding for
spirituality there is a function that
that is serving and what how do we
pursue that and so he became quite
interested in psychedelics and sort of
exten extended whatever you would call
extended sensory experiences or whatever
the sort of more sort of clinical term
for it would be but the idea of of
that is offering you something very
meaningful there's a human need for that
kind of thing right yeah so he's the guy
that you know he's also like got uh he's
very big into meditation i mean look he
he's kind of all over the map in a lot
of ways politically and philosophically
these days uh
and that i that i find fascinating but
he he's an endless uh source of of
interesting thought-provoking things
whether you agree or not and and the
fact that he took such an interest in in
in both meditation and sort of in inward
journey type pursuits and as a function
of that psychedelics for this guy that
has a phd in neuroscience and is like a
super hardcore outspoken
um atheist has always made it
like be a i've always i'm not
like you know i i'm really not a big
user of anything because it's just never
been my scene it's never been i'm one of
those musicians that was like music's
plenty for me uh which maybe makes me
boring i feel safe
he uh he he made that uh he always
pinned that on me or like flagged it as
like you know
i i i certainly have a very uh
egalitarian
attitude about it from the standpoint i
don't give a [ __ ] if anybody egalitaria
is not the right word but i have a very
um
bohemian attitude i guess about it where
i go i don't give a [ __ ] if anybody uses
anything i'm a pretty libertarian
anti-drug war guy in that regard
and uh that one's the only one that
stood out to me is
i really need to carve out a weekend uh
and uh
and uh
get [ __ ] up on mushrooms
mushrooms specifically or or like is it
psilocybin or acid or
it's always been specifically well
psychedelics i guess as a broad category
okay um but because
as i understand they're all incredibly
different experiences
very much funny how i really i you know
it's like i went to college i hung
around a lot of folks on everything you
can imagine uh and yet i never really
scrutinized it i never really i just was
like oh they're in the corner doing
whatever i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah so i'm so i'm i'm profoundly
ignorant to
most all of it mike what about you
so like austin not like something i've
kind of gone out of my way to experience
but i think i've said on the show before
like my thing is like i want to find the
thing that you are personally like a
connoisseur of and i want to experience
it with you so like i've had you know
i've had amazing nights drinking whiskey
with like massive whiskey fans i've had
amazing nights watching a movie marathon
with someone who's upset like i will
find the thing you love and i will be
let you be my tour guide to that and in
the past that has extended to various
experiences um and uh and i'm sure it
will in the future but yeah no but
always legal um but yeah so that's
that's always my approach i i wouldn't
be interested in this from a like on a
personal level i'd be interested in
experiencing it with someone who was a
connoisseur and would would show me the
way i remember there was a friend of
there was somebody i remember that was
like you me and troy need to do
mushrooms together
the life of me who that was
growing up the way that i did it was it
was so
quite literally demonized
that it was just just an invitation you
might as well carve a pentagram on your
chest
and and so look what i did this weekend
you guys want to see my new tattoo
um
i so i never there was always a line
being crossed and there's this new
documentary on netflix going change your
mind i think is what it's called and it
was talking about specifically that
messaging was not limited to my
household nor even like my generation it
was something that was broadcast loudly
by all there was a there was a line of
delineation going no this one even
though like the government created it
right yeah the eye warning is going to
play on your archaic cabinet behind you
while you're saying this absolutely
especially with narc whatever say no to
drugs like that was the whole thing with
the
dare dare uh
when i was growing up we had similar
over here and especially the hippocrates
like if you want to dig into it
especially in the 90s
um like the iran contra scandal if you
want to matter of fact if you watch this
season of the boys which i'm four or
three episodes into right now absolutely
loving it crushing it everyone's doing a
fantastic job but them talking about the
iron iran contra scandal and cocaine and
crack specifically and how that was
specifically sent to
um minority neighborhoods especially
within los angeles and south central
like that was the the hypocrisy in that
is just baffling but um
i grew up with acid is is bad
and so when i had friends that said i'm
i'm gonna go to burning man and i
my plan is to do this i'm like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you like it was it
was such a
sure go go smoke your weed
do your edibles whatever if you're gonna
do mushrooms i guess okay fine
but when you start talking about acids
like there was a conflation with with
like
cocaine acid and heroin it was like kind
of like you just start doing those
things
and it really hasn't been until watching
that
podcast and and
again
i think you it's easy to stand across
the divide of your ignorance from
something and
not allow the the waves of empathy to
pull you closer towards that water and
understand
that there's still a human whoever is
espousing whatever it is that they're
talking about there's a human heart
that's connected to that
and so for me
i also most of these things are just
fundamentally not bad like they're right
like we created a law which they're like
alcohol was never bad in the church it
was jesus drank wine but all of a sudden
you get into prohibition and now there's
this
there are to be clear like there are
most most things have a bad potential
outcome and we should be mindful and
sure but it is also typically in excess
it is exactly that's always in excess as
opposed to inherently bad exactly that's
the thing like
like if all i if i just binged carrots
24 hours a day i'm sure i would reach a
point where if nothing else the severe
malnutrition from only having carrots
would be i told you have i told the
story about the interesting story about
carrots in the second world war on the
show before no this is one this is one
this is gone is it part of the shipping
forecast it's similar so there was so in
the same country
latin please just to bring it home
so in the second world war
british military i think it was they
invented some kind of new radar or
something
uh for their planes and it basically
allowed them to get the drop on a bunch
of you know german playing strategy
yeah and they basically gave them like a
greater viewing distance or whatever
and in order to try and delay the nazis
from knowing what was going on
there was a genuine concern this isn't a
conspiracy theory this is like there's
records of this there's a concerted
propaganda campaign to basically tell
the british public that the reason for
this happening was that the pilots were
on a strict regiment of carrot focus
diet because carrots and this is where
the eyesight thing comes from that's
where and now that's why every
generation since knows carrots they help
your eyesight right it's because
now there is a chemical in them that
apparently makes them but the reason
that that was popularized because our
grandparents were propagandized too
way that
the carrots were the reason the cover
for the effect to cover it all the
effect
and of course the nazis worked out
eventually obviously but that was the
intention
it was just
a
classic
what if they have better
i after being like absolutely not no no
no and um
my friend pete holmes was someone who
grew up very very similar to
to me
and he had he started getting into um
transcendental meditation and started
reading stuff by like richard rohr allen
watts
um and just started thinking about
not only his faith but just spirituality
in a completely different way and i'll
let him tell his own story but
he started experimenting in psychedelics
for the record he pete go ahead no you
can see fruit
he's delivered to burrito
he's who delivered africa he was in the
shower however with david fincher and
kojima um so
he he was the one that was like the
off-camera cannon that is building for
the truck's side of this car
he's really proud of us for being how on
track we've been by the way we've kind
of had a single through line like you
can trace it for the record i'm still
waiting to hear the story of the i've
heard this story before you never even
told the story that you were going to
tell again oh it was the john dimaggio
story
oh when i first got to la there was the
auditions for futurama and i said no and
john remembered that and he was like
yeah thanks man
all right so back to how did you say
that
click click
um
he was like
um
it it changed him like it was an
experience that that he was it was a
formative fundamentally
life expanding
change that's scary though right that
like
that would do would have such an impact
that's that's yeah yeah it is that's
always been that's always been my
resistance from the standpoint that like
i enjoy
when i've had my narrow view of the
drink
well no that's the thing it's like i i
work really hard to not have a narrow
view of life like i i meet a lot of
people i go a lot of places i try a lot
of things i you know i i i'm not afraid
to make an ass out of myself all those
kinds of things you're a card carrying a
member of the sure why not club for sure
yeah and like what's the worst that can
happen is sort of uh like very very few
things where you go what's the worst
case outcome of this scenario very few
things have yeah like very few things
have truly consequential outcomes like
that and so
most things are worth trying at least
once especially
you know if you have your eyes open and
so i um
i
but
i like every time i've gotten sort of
way too drunk and kind of really
properly shit-faced
i don't enjoy the feeling of being out
of control i where i feel like i i'm not
at the wheel and that's the thing that
always that people go you know when it
opens up a whole new dimension i go yeah
but
biochemically i think that's actually
more accurately that you're just not at
the wheel anymore and there is
i don't want to there is an appeal to
that but there is also there's also a
part of me that goes
that that's that i i have a i have an
instinctive uh
resistance maybe that's a flaw but i no
no i'm the exact same way and there have
been i've had really good highs i've had
really bad eyes um
speaking specifically about that two
pete he was like
the it's not that you are not at the
wheel
or that you're not out of control it's
that everything you interact with
you see on a completely different level
so it's you are 100 in control of this
it's just that
that tree you can hear it's it's it's
things of that nature but that's where
my my brain goes just like if you try to
objectively analyze that
you are putting a filter between
yourself in the world our senses are
already a filter between us in the world
that's right your brain is having a
perception
is it is it
or is it removing a filter is it that
that's why trees don't make a sound
right that we know of
well that's where i go objectively yeah
that's i think i'll see a little on this
that's why i look at like that what nasa
released the video of the nasa releasing
the the the sound of the black hole
right now granted that was perfect
example in our favor though like a piece
of equipment can measure it
uh given the right piece you couldn't
hear that given the right piece of
equipment but either a we haven't
invented a piece of equipment yet or b
we are that equipment but is your
supposition that your ear is hearing
stuff that you're unaware of my deposit
is that there's a potential that there
could be not a presupposition at all or
a sub-position i'm i'm not saying that
it is possible i'm not saying that it is
i'm saying that why not
so my my question is
is this creating a false sense
is it going like you said it's putting a
filter on it's like ooh everything looks
like this or is it going let's remove
i always think of this razor would be
that you're dreaming while awake i see
what you're saying i see what you're
saying there's a chemical that's being
released in my brain that is making me
think these things as opposed to
seeing the world for the way that it
really is i don't know
well
when you play a game like mass effect
the whole uh
[Music]
my commander shepard helmet that's
hiding behind that box right
there in the box what's in the box go
ahead
i don't want it in the box look at this
beauty look at that t-shirt with that
one
what a recall
oh man you're ready for a netflix
special [ __ ]
that was good that was really good that
was surgical oh i was in the chamber
just ready for the shot like
nobody else could have delivered that
without that patiently waiting for the
deer to cross into your room
all right go on inside make your mass
effect [ __ ] mass effect the whole
the whole uh like they basically wanted
to create a rpg where you had the
equivalent of magic powers so that you
could have your tank you could have your
hackers you could have your you know
whatever and you could also have like
the people that basically have force
powers and the way they essentially
science their way into it is that some
heretofore undiscovered
matt damon disagrees uh some heretofore
undiscovered
um
you know chemical element they call
element zero essentially unlocks a sense
for all intents purposes that we up till
now have been unaware of and that's
always been a kind of appealing idea
that that
you know you don't know what you don't
know and our science can't measure it
because we haven't built a thing to look
for a thing we don't even know is there
in the same way that if you went back to
the 1600s
and tried to explain to them radio waves
yeah like they yeah
they have no concept that they could be
bathing in them
they don't know they're there technology
aside like ways of being if you went
back in time to the 19th century and
tried to explain rap music to them they
wouldn't like like humans just in and of
ourselves the internet but we have a
capacity just within our own minds to
think of things that we're not thought
of hundreds of years yeah so there is a
hubris in asserting that we now know all
these that we know everything now we
finally reached the point where where we
can it's a very victorian mindset of
everything this is why we're smarter
than all the people that came before and
we have the end of history if you ever
want to be humbled go to crystal palace
in in london where you've where they've
got all the old dinosaur sculptures
where they were absolutely certain and
then if you see the crystal palace
dinosaurs yeah they're all these like
lizard kind of iguanas you know my
favorite they were certain that's what a
dinosaur looked like one of my favorite
demonstrations of this is um
i've watched a lot of like cosmology
lectures on youtube where i can't
remember who it was i think it was
lawrence krauss talked about how
um because of the way that the universe
has expanding and because of the
perpetual
and seemingly unending acceleration of
that expansion you know the whole
redshift of distant galaxies phenomenon
that let us realize that something some
unknown force so-called dark energy is
driving the increased acceleration of uh
galaxies uh apart from each other
eventually they'll be moving away from
us faster than the speed of light
spanning the gap between them which
means
that however many billions or maybe even
trillions of years from now
someone on planet earth in the milky way
would look up into the heavens and see
only the stars of the milky way held
together by local gravity and that there
would be not only no evidence of other
galaxies never mind hundreds of billions
of them but
no way to know have known that ever
existed at all and so their knowledge of
the universe would be confined to what
people believed
you know a couple hundred years ago when
that we had no ability to distinguish
points of light as stars separate from
galaxies when looking at the night sky
and so our our conception of the size of
the universe was much smaller and that
blew my mind to think that there would
be galaxies so far apart from each other
and moving faster like space would be
expanding faster than the speed of light
between those galaxies the galaxies
wouldn't necessarily be moving faster
the speed of light but the expansion of
the space between them would be faster
than the speed of light and everybody
would be a little island unto themselves
that haunted me the first time i thought
i just want to point out
i just want to point out i just want to
point out
yeah
austin is not high
so
i think i think my
i think the way i talked about getting
high demonstrated very clearly that i am
not this man high would be
the
uh it would be the just i think it would
be what i would watch
i think he'd just be sat there kind of
observing i think austin would be i
can't write my head around it but this
is why i'm starting to interrupt mike
this is why i i
i go i'm open to the concept of i i
don't think that the god of the bible
has it at all but this is why i have to
keep a page or finger on that page going
maybe
just because i don't
i don't know i absolutely think that
there's there pam and i were talking
about this too as far as like
dying and and what that actually looks
like i was like to me
when someone goes every every you know
near-death experience that people have
had that is literally just the the
endorphin dump there's a chemical and
i'm sure you guys know what it is or
somebody could tell us what it is that
just just releases the moment of death
and so it fires off it's basically your
mind getting super super high before you
die i'm like combined with white
collagen deprivation and things like
that that will just cause
this crazy amount of euphoria where
people see a white light they feel this
incredible glow i'm like
that to me is a fingerprint of god
right you know what i mean like that's
someone going it could be even with even
with a very sensible kind of
biochemical explanation absolutely
that's just design that's just execution
you know what i mean but that to me i
could look at that and go
man like if i'm trying to think of an
example of like if i
if if we're getting ready for bed and i
know that pam needs a glass of water
before she goes to bed
and so
i come and i get her a glass of water
and i set it on her nightstand and she
just walks in and finds a glass of water
in her nightstand
she doesn't have to know that it was me
that did that she just knows that she
needed hand to god
that it did that so when i look at that
i'm not saying that god did that what
i'm saying abigail breslin and you have
glasses of water all over your bedroom
swing for the fences these signs yeah
i got it
i just think that you could look at that
and go hey i got you and that and the
moment where you need it most and the
moment where you're going to feel the
most alone
i got you a little present a little
present and to me
before you go to bed pam feels her most
alone yes but also he's because he's
watching videos on this works for us
that's my second question i'll just say
one more thing that i'll hand out
the the notion of does something happen
after we die
absolutely categorically yes
absolutely matter can either be created
or destroyed we look and we see the
system of what happens to energy a star
explodes and it goes off and it forms
planets and and
or new stars are being born all the time
energy is constantly being recirculated
and therefore redistributed into new
things so i absolutely believe i think
the arrogance of humanity and hubris
like you said will not allow us to
accept the fact that something happens
after we die
we're just never going to be aware of it
and that's what most people have a hard
time including myself letting go of is
that that i won't be invited to the
party that happens afterwards so to
answer your original question maybe my
issue with burning man is the fact that
i do feel a left out mike doesn't like
you before do you
i guess i was just gonna say that like
the atheistic kind of stance i would
take here is that like
a glass of water is appreciated and
beautiful you don't necessarily
need an explanation
absolutely to exist
absolutely you can just say you know
what that is a there is a there is a by
weird happenstance of biology this thing
happens that makes death a little bit
less horrible but do you think that
you don't need well you can be you can
find beauty and nature without having to
ascribe an author to it you can say this
is wonderful
this is beautiful this is magical this
is poetic this is
everything but do you not think that
happenstance is is a diminishing of the
design of i think it's more impressive
that the world is inherently beautiful
because but also crucially as well there
is also the the biomechanical
explanation which is we think the
world's beautiful because we have
evolved to live and exploit in the world
so therefore
we
we think of sunsets beautiful because on
a biological level the sunrise and
sunset has kept off our species going
but there it is they're but even they're
even separate it is beautiful abstract
random beauty is still beautiful then
it's beautiful that something unguided
yeah through purp through conscious
means unconscious bottom-up quote design
can yield something as beautiful and
disparate as the animals we see the the
eco the all everything about the
ecosystem the plant world the eukaryotes
the the funguses everything all in this
massive crazy interwoven sort of
tapestry of life the fact that that all
happens as just a series of interactions
to me that is actually the unguided
nature of it is what's so beautiful yes
uh i don't think the faithful have a
monopoly on finding beauty i think i
agree 100 it's simply an explanation to
it and it's a very in most cases it's a
very cheap one and i'm not disparaging
anyone that is a person of faith of any
faith of course i'm just simply saying
it is a very
it's a very easy and i would always
encourage anybody of any faith or no
faith to constantly challenge that
viewpoint it either reaffirms the the
position that you have or it allows you
to allows me to find a new version of
that but specifically to the sunrise and
sunset thing the reason why we find
those things appealing and beautiful and
poetic is because we need it
there is a certain biological thing that
happens there's there's cells in the
bottom of your iris that when you get
low angle sunlight early in the morning
fires off a chemical reaction in your
body to
boost cortisol levels so that your body
temperature rises so that you set your
circadian clock so that you feel more
awake and that lets you know morning you
get up
inversely to that is when the sun is
going down same thing you see the sun
going down it tells your body it's time
to go to bed so there's a reason why we
love oh my gosh that's so pam and i do
this every morning we watch the sunrise
and it's like god damn it's beautiful
the reason why is my body's going i need
that so much there's a chemical
not dependency upon that but there's
definitely a relationship between that
that spectrum of light hitting my eyes
and doing something in my body
we're interconnected and i think humans
are very prone to an arrogance where we
don't think of ourselves as a part of
the natural order of the of the planet
the cosmos we think of ourselves as a
part or above or separate or observing
these things rather than being
integrated as a part of that system yeah
um and that's what you're describing is
of course we feel that way we're part of
we're star stuff we're made from there's
literally the same stuff that's in our
body is what's in a star that is on the
journey this episode what i love is it
definitely is a it's definitely a
lawrence krauss quote where he talks
about the atom
what's more in addition to being star
stuff
um just to give you a sense of
the
the miracle that
various atoms from throughout the
universe would come together to form you
to to celebrate in the some of us more
miraculous than others
sort of
to celebrate in the um
in the inherent beauty of the
improbability that is one's self
the atoms from your left hand this is
his quote the atoms in your left hand
almost undoubtedly came from a different
star from atoms in your right hand so
the idea that like it's you're not even
from a source you're like bits of
everywhere
uh and that that to me again that's that
interconnectedness especially because
it's all quite understandable and we're
obviously still we have you know the
overwhelming majority of knowable facts
still to learn but we know a fair bit as
a collective species and and and all
that learned just makes it more
interesting and beautiful so how cool is
it just brain how cool is it that your
brain and all of our brains like
take the thing you just said about the
left hand one star right hand one star
and even though you basically just
described a sequence of uh verifiable
objective facts
our minds all have this poetic level to
them that it sounds beautiful like that
interpretation is in itself a thing of
beauty yeah that's that's a very you
like in trends obviously there's amazing
kind of words misery from the person
that quotes originally from but at the
same time you are as the listener being
touched by that
manifesting kind of a poetic beauty
yourself just from the way your brain
puts those words together and and puts
meaning into it that's
phenomenal this episode of play watch
listen has been brought to you by edna's
edibles edna's edibles made
the best edibles if you're going to get
high get high with edna
tedious
was there even like a glancing blow at
video games in this uh
[Laughter]
yeah i feel like uh i feel like uh
actually the funny thing is i had some
thoughts that i was very curious to get
nobody gives a [ __ ] opinions on but yeah
no i mean once you go to levels of like
cosmic grade spirituality whatever mike
had everything feels like the button it
was like it's beautiful
i did a shitty joke
you need to pick the conversation that
back up do the intro let's get out of
here we gotta go back to work it's all
gonna get cut no it's not uh all right
well i guess since i've been googling i
am the alana this week so
that's how it usually sounds to me um
uh
that's my
exhausted game director my perspective
troy a totally baked game actor
and i'm austin
uh a shilling
uh
shameless composer who's excited to say
that aliens uh fireteam pathogen came
out today okay bye